who know where the fire came from I'm
saying is that once you start digging
into shipment the whole essence of it is
disappeared the fact that people
speculate how was it made like I think
that's just best for the sandwich I
think that's what makes it more unique
and just like a myth that I'm saying
like it makes it a relic and I'm saying
like where the [ __ ] this [ __ ] is act
like it's just so special we need this
[ __ ] so that's not digging to it man I'm
saying let's keep our mouths shut
let's keep our eyes closed this is
enjoying them all [ __ ] eat it and
keep it pushing their hometown hero the
legend of New York's chopped cheese
15 years here I've never had a job James
what is the chopped cheese is that a
grilled cheese sandwich never heard of
it ah you're talking like an Italian
cheese burger
honestly I first heard about chopped
cheese from my daughter who just started
working in Harlem I have no idea what it
is my I imagine just like someone took
like a stack of American cheese and it's
shafted I was born in New York so I'm
gonna be 70 in a couple of months I
don't know I don't know if I've even
heard of that a sandwich before chopped
cheese I have never heard of this
sandwich in any kind of MIT bodega and
any kind of food establishment if I
could hidden secret how would I describe
it chopped cheese I sold the easiest
description will be a steak and cheese
but instead of it being action steak its
hamburger meat and you chop it up don't
whatever kind of cheese you want
whatever kind of toppings you want the
best description I would say is a
wonderful magical sandwich that has
tested times and it's mythical when it's
theirs one of the best thing which has
ever created in New York if you want to
understand New York then you got to
understand the chopped cheese despite
its status as a bodega icon the
sandwiches never gain a recognition of
more mainstream staples like hot dogs
and bagels but a recent wave of
attention including a prime-time cameo
and Anthony Bourdain's parts unknown has
caused fierce debate about who the same
which belongs to and what it means to
New York City what
chopped cheese yeah what is trapped I
have to I have to see where does this
come from this some mutant cheese we get
the chop cheese that's ground these
letters in the toast about food so if
you want to make that frankly [ __ ] feel
like 3:00 in the morning
Aki [ __ ] like like I need it like a
chopped cheese right now this is New
York City's answer to the Philly
cheesesteak and most New Yorkers don't
even know it exists it's chopped up
ground beef
American cheese lettuce tomato mayo and
ketchup so it's almost like eating a
cheeseburger but it's just on a sub roll
a [ __ ] sub roll the [ __ ] Midwest
get the [ __ ] [ __ ] the [ __ ] door
it's called a [ __ ] hero I was
basically going down my timeline I saw
this caption that said New York City's
answer to the Philly cheesesteak and I'm
already you know inside of food is
notorious for finding foods so I'm like
when I thought of something like oh
don't tell me they did it
don't tell me it's the Cobb cheese I
click on the video in a stick shop
cheese of course
this is New York City's answer to the
Philly cheesesteak it's not a Philly
cheesesteak it's a completely different
sandwich and like everyone knows I'm
from Harlem all of my friends were like
oh you got to make a response to this we
took a trip up to Harlem to get the [ __ ]
out now that [ __ ] know that a Philly
cheesesteak ain't the same thing as a
chop cheese right and they're not
different versions of each other right
it's two different [ __ ] things yeah
[ __ ] got Columbus syndrome and
[ __ ] want to be exploring and
discovering [ __ ] what the Christopher
Columbus do he came saw some land there
were people on it yet he just completely
ignored that and said yeah we discovered
America boom like we're here and that's
basically kind of like what it was with
like a chop cheese wait nobody in New
York City knows about it right and most
New Yorkers don't even know it exists
wow this is so cheap like we discovered
this new restaurant that nobody knows
about meanwhile everyone's been coming
to this restaurant for like their entire
life oh my god Becky only $4 that's such
a steal that's what happens with West
Harlem as more tourists start to come
and it becomes a sort of landmark or a
sort of tourist stop where everyone
wants to come and buy these cheap things
I feel like the chopped cheese one day
is going to be served on like a panini
like pita bread with like you know like
toasted down for like $13 and served at
like 5-star restaurants just don't be
coming to our hood and try to raise the
prices it's like if you want to bring it
back to your town you know where y'all
can afford that [ __ ] y'all making you
know six figures or whatever look
[ __ ] make it eleven dollars in
Williamsburg out in Brooklyn a butcher
shop did just that getting New York
Times coverage for its high intake on
the job cheese their version raises
questions about the difference between
respectful tribute and blatant ripoff
ground beef breast fed breasts finished
American cheese banana peppers because I
wouldn't feel comfortable without them a
little relish of mustard pickle relish
and ketchup classic long roll juicy
tomato juicy lettuce secret ingredient
hot mr. mustard hot mustard and our
world-famous marrow butter we wanted to
be ripping on because we want full full
browning kind of like smash burger style
and that's the kind of the approach that
I have when we first started serving and
put it on the menu we knew that people
wouldn't know what it was it definitely
was not expecting like a this complete
tidal wave of like attention for this
one little sandwich first of all when
people else came in for his three-day
tasting it was kind of like a joke like
an inside joke kind of like pee Wells is
back and then for him to write about it
was just the cherry on top I have a
feeling it was his first experience with
it there's a fine line between just
complete copying the complete pirating
of ideas and in tributing and and and
referencing and honoring I mean that's
kind of our vibe of the meathook in
general we're sort of borrowing a lot
from different regions and cultures our
hardest job is trying to impart to
people why it is that we need to charge
what we do particularly for anything
that involves beef at some point our
beef is going to be so tainted that the
corner shop is not going to be able to
sell chopped cheese's anymore people
come and visit our shop and they take
away something and they go back to their
and they can say hey well these guys are
serving like a sustainable limp
sustainably raised like grass-fed
grass-finished chopped cheese I'm able
to really show that I'm a lover I'm not
a hater I'm here to like spread the
gospel I'm here to show people like this
is my version this is our version I
think we need more versions i think i
think it's a sandwich worthy of being
copied and of being replicated
everywhere house deli in queens is home
to another version the bodega doesn't
claim to have invented the chopped
cheese but its fans are fiercely loyal
to what they think is the best tasting
one in the city but even more so some
feel like taking the chopped cheese out
of its natural environment its swagger
jacking at its worst
I know Williamsburg is [ __ ] the
chopped cheese up I know they are
trashing the chopped cheese bow so
you're talking to that is bad news like
this is terrible news the fact that
Williamsburg is stealing a chopped
cheese is selling it for 11 cash doesn't
surprise me cuz that's what's already
happening in Waynesburg a delight who's
from Williamsburg doesn't even live in
Williamsburg anymore probably awesome
like Reuben [ __ ] bread artisan row
some bombers reddit cheese is spread
among a side of bread hello quinoa a
little kale instead of lettuce as I get
in the worst jerks for the highest price
is just gonna make sense yeah we all get
a holiday right now iconic chop cheese
spot I'm staying on the corner of Hollis
and francis Lewis gonna stop some spot
elbow so I'm saying we pull up here on
the late night full of E to get good
eats and of course the major key to
half-and-half have a have have water and
maybe half a pound of Domino service
rack in a cutlet first roll for some
reason the howlers deli just makes they
[ __ ] extra messy so one bite pause and
everything is falling out I mean the
most important
some people forget though the grill
gotta be dirty
everyone's le in the grill is clean
don't you don't you don't want to eat
there because it's got to have at least
a B rating if you if your Deli has a
rating you don't want the lower the
lower the letter grade the higher
quality of the penis you can change
every other things that the cook made in
that day if he made a big negatives you
chaste wrote on this right now I taste
eggs and grits too right it's not very
yeah hey [ __ ] my [ __ ] up twice over here
they will they won't [ __ ] you all around
fiance this is part of the culture I got
mail here's the thing if you're ordering
the chopped cheese you don't have to
look at the menu because that means
you're from here like you know what the
culture is you're not ordering at
options of the menu if somebody's
looking at the menu they probably don't
belong in there to be honest I really
think it's a hotel with I just think
it's in every good like here's New York
City here's a hood here the hood and
chopped you there a tucked like you need
a check sir
we got on the taco bar listen what you
say yeah I'm calling hey listen you boss
Hey Tati's Lee I'll get you one right
here talk about it bro do it see this is
why I hope you go through this is why we
eat chop cheese I bet you in
Williamsburg if you go to get a chop
cheese no cop is gonna come bother you
like that they try to take everything
else from this New York swag New York
rap in New York everything at least let
us keep the chop
cheese really present one place where
the chop cheese has been rooted for
years is the Bronx the home to a cooking
collective known as ghetto gastro the
group created their own high-end version
of the sandwich while still staying true
to their neighborhood influences even so
they argue that not all chefs have
license to remix the food they grew up
with well we in a ghetto gastro Test
Kitchen and the Andrew Friedman a k2
trap to us an amalgam of coach and a
bronze trying to read it follow the word
ghetto through the culinary part a lot
of this kind of drama grew up in the
streets a lot a lot of the dishes that
you're going to have our element that
might seem familiar from like New York
City urban cuisine but we just read
apartment so I used to go to church on
Harlem and I was about six years old my
first girlfriend Shakera what's up babe
we cut Church and left she's like yo
let's go get a chop cheese and I'm like
yeah what's that like she's like it's a
sandwich you don't this like 92 I'm like
mad never heard of this so she put me
onto the chop cheese and you know that
kind of solidified the love in our
relationship it's uptown like the
culture of the Bronx and Harlem is like
the borough's are almost there like
relatives they're like sisters are
really close cousins so for me it's like
the same [ __ ] you feel me
but if this was selling a restaurant
probably like what 64 all of this
Colbert and then at that point we can't
call it the Chop cheese no more we call
it that chopsticks
you might get a child cheese on a block
at your local bodega but when you
rapping with ghetto gastro you going to
get that chopped Steve I think it's so
regional and it's like a fairly new
creation
but this chopped cheese is something
like that started in our lifetime I
think you still have youth youth that
have ownership over that food something
like a tortilla that foods been around
for a thousand years 2,000 years you
know so people aren't as angry about it
it's been a part of American culture for
longer I mean getting back to the
question of April Bloomfield but when
you're charging $15 per sandwich that's
four dollars and your place is called
white bowl I mean you kind of have you
found opening those like come on you
know you're throwing it over the plate
I'm a firm believer that once you put
something out in the world and you
created a lot of it belongs to you so
it's like people need whatever the [ __ ]
they want but like that also opens you
up to criticism you know just like our
iPad like what's your relationship with
the chopped cheese I think there was
something to the effect that you could
have a guilt-free and I was like what
the [ __ ] does that mean like you know
that made the food that I eat is like I
don't feel guilty it is not cheese I
mean Mya's is a way to describe on the
menu or when they bring the food out
they're like you know this is where this
originated from or even put something
like that on the menu maybe pay homage
like that maybe like Hajis chop cheese I
mean it would be almost insane like if
you really want any options you really
wanted to pay homage imagine April
Bloomfield running top-notch chef
climbing a sandwich for $4 I think
that'll be awesome awesome challenge -
can you do for $5 like what Brooks is
doing at superiority burger like he's
going for foot out of sandwiches find
out the senators that are awesome
because it's always like the poverty
tourism digging for gold in the hood or
whatever good foraging I like to call it
maybe there's a way where portion of
their proceeds to go to organization
like Edible Schoolyard
that are doing edible gardens in these
neighborhoods in East Harlem Brooklyn
and the Bronx we're their order in chop
Cheney but his farm is like the best
chopped cheese that I know I would say
it's over there 170 Cisco Road I mean I
don't know also can't forget about Hajis
in Harlem you know big shout out uptown
I mean the quest to discover the roots
of chop cheese brings us to Spanish
Harlem the spiritual birthplace of the
sandwich where one bodega in particular
has been credited with starting the wave
of chop cheese claims of invention are
difficult to verify
but loyalists of the bodega are
convinced that The Legend of chopped
cheese began right here on the corner of
1st Ave and one hundred and tenth Street
hey guys welcome to Spanish Harlem thank
you for stopping by
Hadjis groceries deli it's about time
that somebody get recognition to the
famous famous chopped cheese and Spanish
Harlem
I feel of New York City forget what you
heard and what you've seen this is where
chop cheese originated from but anybody
who know anything about that sandwich or
anything about Harlem culture Spanish
Harlem culture they know that it came
from Hodgins first of all you gotta give
him less the keys to college he's the
one that really mastered it and put it
together show these gentlemen how to do
it five years ago when it's just started
poppin off because you had a lot of um
you had a lot of white people going
uptown that's what they got I'm saying
we went uptown but this had been here
for two decades that's why I became the
hub and anybody who denies they don't
they don't really know what's going on
they really know little culture not
becoming here for about ten years
yeah we come
time in Chaves or so the best shop
cheese sandwich in the area that's all I
hear when I come in I live right above
taste good
all right it never changes with the best
hangover food see Hajis like they won
the first bodegas in the neighborhood
that would that became a key I'm saying
before that was a lot of Puerto Rican
live Dominicans well Aki means is the
term we give to the Pakistani ins or the
Afghanistan's standings that lived at
that common working the bodega comb
Atkins show for whatever I'm saying the
same way um
[ __ ] called me Papi's the
saying like this it's a term of
endearment the chopped cheese sandwich
was different because it was different
people 20 years ago when they were the
only people with the chopped cheese they
were the only [ __ ] that was
Aki's in there - home Yemen my country
they have some something called a FAFSA
and some call it doctor that means like
the the minds me that isn't me you know
chapter onion green pepper with
vegetable stuff and make it nice the
shop Jesus got to come from I remember
being a young mother [ __ ] I hate seeing
DMS come out here Damon - god bless when
Aleeah was alive he would bring Ali over
here Jim Jones tips ecru camera families
right down the block they live 1199 or
become family come and show some videos
here
colonial hey hey take this store is like
a fixture like high Katz's with a
pastrami sandwiches down downtown I
don't know to me but they gotta have
their own name you're still saying like
we just call [ __ ] the bodega like I'm
going to bodega on 111th this has at his
own name Hajis washy a lot of people
different people from Brooklyn for my
hat time for downtown for Westside they
come for everybody come from the Chukchi
most of the people here they like the
captions more than any other stuff I
make like 150 like 200 250 on the
weekend sometimes we we ran out of the
way the brain is the key element and to
making a good sandwich now the
difference is something called
not blank chart it's like an iron to
iron put together that flattens the
bread so the best time to eat a chopped
cheese for me will be at the we I was in
the morning man 2/3 the devil's hours
with the fries come out at night when
you ha amazing I'm saying cuz you know
this ain't miss a filet mignon meat your
saber where you eyes gonna feel like
that [ __ ] is Searle on state that's why
another reason why it's so popular - cuz
of the price five five fifty depending
where you whet three dollars you get on
the road you know I'm saying like on the
roll is cheaper once mainstream get it
they throw their little price on it man
you know man they gonna have to raise it
because we've been cooking this sandwich
for 20 years
these [ __ ] it's charging
tonight for the [ __ ] or not man we
gettin raped we got to put it up I'm not
mad at me I'm not mad at Anthony
Bourdain man I'm not mad at Andrew
Lagasse wanna make it on his show I
would love the scene in the
[ __ ] restaurant in Kentucky
that's fire because you had a piece of
Spanish all in the Kentucky I'm saying
that's important I think it has become a
premier New York sandwich absolutely
besides pizza we never really had that
one like kind of sandwich that really
stood out in New York culture and I feel
like this has become that clear winner
of that we always want to be number one
really won't be a competition we're from
New York while we are on the sandwich
that's from cinema nice over like now we
got our own [ __ ] so let's get a chopped
cheese